batteries may be small but for the
United Auto Workers Union they're a big
deal it's going to change the future of
our Union and the future of our industry
at least 25,000 members of the UAW have
been striking simultaneously at plants
owned by GM Ford and stellantis as they
demand increased pay and better job
security and at the heart of their
negotiations lies a question around how
the UAW will fit into automaker plans to
build more and more EVs and whether the
workers who make these will become
unionized this Union is really fighting
over positions that aren't made yet so
what do America's EV and Battery
Ambitions mean for the future of the UAW
let's find
out all the workers union all the
workers un so this is the first time in
the uaw's almost 90-year history that
the group has gone on strike at all
three automakers at the same time part
of the uaw's demands have been for cost
of living adjustments the right to
strike over plank closures and a 40% pay
rise over the next four years and
negotiations have been tricky so I tell
you what I'm going to do with with their
proposal I'm going to file it in its
proper place cuz that's where it belongs
the trash a lot of the tension has been
around where the money for that 40% pay
rise could come from and to help explain
why here's wsj's Autos reporter Norah
eart okay webcam sorry George I might
need to get warmed up a little bit here
this is coming at a time where the
automakers are really focused on keeping
costs lower they can so that they can
fund the transition to producing EVS
part of that expense is because the raw
materials needed to make EVS can cost up
to 125% more than those used in internal
combustion engine or ice vehicles but
the union has said that the companies
can afford their demands even as they're
funneling billions of dollars into this
EV transition when the big thre say the
future is uncertain and that the EV
transition's expensive remember that
they've made a quarter of a trillion in
North American profits over the last
decade but when it comes to EV
manufacturing the bigger concern for the
UAW is around job security see the
transition from making gas cars to
electric ones is dramatically reshaping
how many Auto Workers are needed and
what those roles are while tasks like
installing interior trim or fitting
seats are unlikely to change much in the
transition roles that center around
building the combustion engine are at
risk according to Congressional research
that could mean nearly 150,000 jobs are
exposed and even Ford's own CEO Jim
Farley once told a conference the EVS
would require 40% less labor than ice
vehicles but the automakers have assured
workers that as many of those jobs will
be transitioned as possible so they'll
be moving folks over from these ice
plants to EV plants while jobs on
combustion engine and transmission
production lines are likely to be phased
out new jobs in new battery
manufacturing facilities will spring up
but that could still present a major
issue for the UAW the plan was to draw
down engine and transmission plants and
permanently replace them with low wage
battery jobs see most of the new battery
factories aren't 100% owned and operated
by automakers they're joint ventures GM
has a factory with LG and plans for two
more Ford has plans for several with SK
on and stellantis has teamed up with
Samsung for its factories and the
problem for the UAW is that these
factories aren't automatically unionized
and the union is fighting for the
security of those future jobs which is
really interesting but that appears to
be changing in December 2022 the workers
at LG and GM's battery facility voted to
unionize and fast forward to the present
day GM has now agreed in writing to
place their electric battery
manufacturing under our national Master
agreement what this will mean for our
membership cannot be understated the
question now is whether GM's agreement
will set the stage for other automakers
battery facilities to follow suit if
that happens it could drive costs up for
these automakers the average hourly
labor costs for a unionized OEM is
around $65 an hour according to Industry
data whereas Tesla which currently isn't
unionized has hourly labor costs of
around $45 an hour and so if these
automakers pay their workers union rates
at their battery facilities it could
make them less cost competitive compared
to the likes of Tesla or foreign
manufacturers like those in Asia
throughout this whole bargaining process
the automakers have sort of repeated
this Mantra of we cannot be competitive
companies if our labor costs inflate as
much as the Union's demands would make
them but if automakers don't come to an
agreement with the UAW they may struggle
to make Vehicles altogether I've heard
members who want to bring down the
hammer strike all the truck plants hit
the big three where it hurts and there
is a time and place for that and believe
me if the big three don't continue to
make progress that time's going to be
coming real soon so even though the
strikes have gone on for weeks this
could just be the very beginning of a
long road ahead for the
UAW